on a l'impression qu'on est devant un
éternel recommencement et je ne parle
pas de la neige qui tombe en hiver mais
bien de la collusion à montréal dans un
rapport qui a été déposée hier au
conseil de ville le vérificateur général
de montréal soupçonne la présence de
collusion dans l'attribution des
contrats donc de déneigement mais aussi
d' enlèvement des ordures et aussi de
matières recyclables à montréal
jean-sébastien bon on a on a suivi la
commission charbonneau on a suivi les
ripoux on a suivi les fonctionnaires qui
s'excusait et là on se demande vraiment
jusqu'où ça va aller
est ce qu'il y aura une fin à tout ça
parce que fondamentalement la question
de fond c'est est ce que les citoyens de
montréal paient trop cher pour ses
services qui sont essentiels évidemment
mais si ça se confirme effectivement il
paie probablement trop cher d'ailleurs
jacques bergeron
le vérificateur général de la ville
écrit dans son rapport que ça ne
favorise évidemment pas de des coûts à
la baisse si vous voulez lorsqu'on
demande un service parle de collusion
possible ou probable probable dans le
cas de la collecte et du transport des
déchets parle de nombreux indices qui
laisse croire cela pour vous donner
quelques exemples il ya quelques
entreprises seulement qu'ils recueillent
tous les contrats dans des nombreux
arrondissements
autre exemple parfois les documents
d'appel d'offres
beaucoup de gens vont les chercher à
l'hôtel de ville et après ça il ya un
seul soumissionnaire autre exemple bon
document ne pas le fait que parfois on
choisit le soumissionnaire qui offre un
prix plus élevé que d'autres alors ce ne
sont que quelques exemples on a parlé de
ça certains montréalais patrice inutile
de vous dire que quand on parle d'une
collusion possible
il ya beaucoup de cynisme pas du tout
vous décourage à l'instant oui avec
toutes les choses qui pensent en ville
oui c'est sûr ben je pense qu'en toutes
sortes de voiliers réglé je puisse faire
c'est une bonne affaire car non
seulement voilà public fois ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui aurait dû
être vérifiée depuis assez longtemps je
pense que c'est
c'est primaire et en tant que payeur de
taxes je pense que c'est absolument
nécessaire de faire un changement au
moins au moins
les plus avertis qu'est ce que vous
demandez à l'inspecteur général de falla
tout cas la commission ouvre les livres
qui vous voulez vous aussi
même charles sa transparence
l'ajustement l'inspecteur général denis
gallant on lui a parlé cet après midi il
est en fonction depuis le 25 février
actuellement il ya une dizaine de
personnes qui travaillent autour de lui
ils seront bientôt 25
je lui ai demandé qu'est ce qu'ils
pensaient qu'est ce qu'il avait à dire
donc sur ce rapport du vérificateur
général et particulièrement sur ces cas
de collusion possible je laisse écouter
denis gallant je vais lui les rapports
de 14 général c'est très étoffé de
travail de longue haleine effectivement
tableau chiffres à l'appui
et effectivement et ce dossier lowey ce
que le vérificateur général nous
transmet ce dossier là ils ont fait un
travail remarquable meynard est du
travail des analyses très pointues donc
du travail de terrain à part et la loi
créant un inspecteur général à la ville
de montréal a été sanctionné vendredi
dernier donc mais dont nous avons besoin
qatar ou les prêts pouvoir pour aller
inquiéter
alors on attend les résultats de ses
pleins pouvoirs chez le shérif de la
ville chez l'inspecteur général on a
entendu plus haut dans le bulletin le
maire de montréal monsieur bergeron qui
disait justement ça prouve qu'on avait
besoin d'un inspecteur d'autres
réactions
ouais mais pour en revenir à monsieur
coderre d'ailleurs et disait c'est bon
de le mentionner que dans les travaux
publics depuis que la ville a changé ses
règlements depuis qu'existe la
commission charbonneau et cetera on
aurait sauvé 25 à 30%
imaginez d'économies alors on espère que
ça va se produire aussi dans les
domaines des déchets du déneigement j'ai
parlé à réal ménard maire de hochelaga
maisonneuve voici ce qu'il avait à dire
là dessus
moi comme gestionnaire des fonds publics
qui a donné des millions de contrats
pour des services essentiels
la question du prix est toujours la
première variable mais s'il ya des
façons haute de faire évidemment on est
prêt à regarder ça mais moi je considère
qu'il faut maintenant voir ça dans un
cadre qui ne peut être que préventive à
ce moment ci
alors voilà du pain sur la planche
patrice pour denis gallant le nouvel
inspecteur général de montréal c'est une
grosse grosse partie du budget de la
ville de montréal qui va donc pour le
déneigement et pour la cueillette des
ordures c'est une évidence
merci à janssen on va